These people keep doxing. These people aren't worthy of moral
consideration. He said this multiple times and that is a direct
endorsement of Destiny's doxing campaign and any other doxing
or harassment that might go on. If he's going to step into it
like that, then yeah, I'm going to talk about you. Going to talk
about you. I'm going to I'm going to say whatever I actually
think about you. I'm not going to hold back normally. And these
people don't realize it. I keep the temperature turned down cuz
I don't want anybody to feel like I'm trying to get them harassed
or anything like that. But if you're going to straight up like
green light whatever the on me, right? You're going to greenlight
whatever harassment on me, whatever whatever doxing anything
on my community members, then you forever
guess he loses the lawsuit to Pixie. I like trust me I don't
think
unless they unless they somehow get like Discord logs showing
that he did this which I don't know if they got any subpoenas
or any retention things that actually would allow them to do
this then I don't think they can I don't think they'll win on
their current evidence. I don't think the current evidence as
it stands is enough to go actually actually
like we're going to find a big judgment on Pixie's Bath. You
want to do a full-blown Kelly mention ban, we can do that. Well,
I don't really need it to affect general chat in the Discord.
I just in in chat in general, it's like if people are like, "Oh,
you should you should bring Kelly back." I'm just like, "No,
just time you out." I just that behavior will just disappear
from the chat. Even ironically,
I just don't want association.
Um, but in the Discord, I don't really care because I know there
are people who are in both communities. I don't want to like
I don't want to totally ban them. I do I don't want like crossosting
trying to form drama between the two communities, but if you're
just like talking about Kelly because she said something is fine.
Bring Carrier back into stream. Carrier is just there's just
never be any purpose. The person I talked to today was just like
Carrier. It's like actually depressing to even think that people
like this exist. I'll be real. H I don't want to I I don't want
any sort of reputation for leaking DMs, so I'm like not going
to do it. But holy, man. Like holy actually.
Okay, so we got this clip. I think we go from this one to
He probably addressed the mutant thing in this. Wait, if I click
on this time stamp, I think they he just tried to present it.
I can do the mutin thing in two seconds. Hold on. Let me just
It's like right here at the end, right? >> Every time him
watching the rant about mutin. I'll just watch his reaction to
it. Um,
yeah, I'm I'm going to zoom in because I'm a little concerned
about them spamming like uh possible docs info in the chat, you
know. This is true. Yes, we found a new EPG. >> So, I'm
I'll just read cuz this guy's got pictures of this rose girl
posted everywhere, too, which is a little bit weird. And oh,
wait, hold on. That's Didn't he comment? I thought he commented
on this. >> He should have roasted Kiwi Farms. That's Oh,
well, there's that one. Hold on. any evidence of this happening?
Any evidence that I had anything to do with it that I didn't
disavow it? Okay, I'm I was going to describe it because I'm
not going to go splunk around in this VOD. Um, he basically says
that the only reason I'm going after Mutin is cuz Mutin is back
on his stream and that I would never have harassed Mutton unless
went back on the stream. When in fact, when I'm talking about
I'm telling people like don't go after him, don't like on him,
whatever. Was when he rejoined the stream, I said don't [__]
on him. Don't go after him. Like guys got to make a bag. I get
it. It's fine. It was when he finally started saying, and he
said it multiple times, that these people referring to my community
are not worthy of moral consideration,
endorsing doxing and whatever harassment comes with that. And
he said this multiple times, these people keep doxing. These
people aren't worthy of moral consideration. He said this multiple
times and that is a direct endorsement of Destiny's doxing campaign
and any other doxing or harassment that might go on. If he's
going to step into it like that, then yeah, I'm gonna talk [__]
about you. Talk about you. I'm gonna I'm gonna say whatever I
actually think about you. I'm not going to hold back normally.
And these people don't realize it. I keep the temperature turned
down cuz I don't want anybody to feel like I'm trying to get
them harassed or anything like that. But if you're going to straight
up like green light whatever the on me, right? You're going to
greenlight whatever harassment on me, whatever whatever doxing
anything on my community members, then [__] you
>> I mean, if I still don't endorse
doxing you, harassing you in real life, any I don't even endorse
like DMing you to harass you. I I endorse no direct harassment
of any kind. I endorse literally just me venting about what a
piece of you are for not having any idea about this situation.
You would never have a talk about this directly with anyone,
right? You're a total coward. You'd never have this conversation
with anybody. You can't prove anything you think. You are just
a mindless drone who shows up to suck Destiny's for money. That's
you. And [__] you.
That's it. I'd probably even stay away from the appearance attacks
from now on. But it's like actually insane that people will moralize
>> deserve any moral consideration at that >> Well,
they do deserve more. Well, THEY'RE NOT. >> YEAH. [laughter]
IT'S JUST LIKE THAT. Like you're just stepping into the arena,
right? You're like explicitly
stepping into the arena trying to get in a fight.
If Mutin wants to have a conversation. I tried I tried to go
to Dan. Okay. Not that I talked to Dan. I've never talked to
Dan before. But I I was like, "Hey, I'll call in and talk to
this guy. I'll apologize for the appearance attacks." Okay. I'll
actually apologize for those,
but I just want to know what he actually why he actually thinks
this is happening. I want to know why he actually like endorses
the doxing campaign, why he endorses the harassment, cuz I think
I know,
but he has to understand that like at some point
I believe
I believe he got hit as well by Kiwi Farms. Okay, I'll just I'll
just say I'm not going to say but it was after it was considerably
after Destiny had started his doxing campaign. Moon should understand
that by coming into the stream, signing up to be like the guy
who's going to say it's, "Oh, it's morally justified to dox these
people." By being that guy, you have under Destiny's worldview,
under his idea of how things should work, you have signed up
for that that exact action to be taken against you. You have
explicitly done so. That's not my fault.
I don't endorse it. I think it's awful cuz I don't need to over
stuff on the internet like wish people to feel in fear of their
safety in any way. I don't want that. But when you step into
the arena, you're willing to endorse all of these tactics. And
then Destiny's opinion is, well, if you're even remotely adjacent
to this, you're you're a target, right? Destiny's opinion is,
well, Pisco let somebody talk about me in his chat, so Pisco
is a target. Now, that's Destiny's world, right?
Mutton has to understand that he has signed up for this. I hope.
And again, uh, if I ever found out that you were, even even if
there were like reports of you guys going to Mutton's chat and
like calling him an Sler or something, I would ban you. Just
so you know, when you come here and you consume this content,
if you're going to go as a member of this community and try to
harass this guy or harass people around him, you will just get
banned.
I get to vent. You don't get to vent. Okay? Or you don't get
to vent outside of this chat is how it is. You are so soy. I
I know. I know. It's so gay. I know. Every time it's so gay.
Okay, so you have to be able to prove they're evil, which is
basically subjective standard. Mr. Moot 100%. Mr. Moot would
100% accept a like 20 mark bonus to be the guy who pulls the
lever on the gas chambers, right? Like that's just facts. That's
just facts. And we don't like anti-semites here, Mr. Moot. We
don't like anti-semites here. Okay. Kind of not welcome around
here. Anyway,
was the clip? Well, that was one of the clips there. I think
there are multiple moments where he does this, including which
I didn't know when I went on the the rant, I don't believe. Um,
including one where Destiny goes, whoa. Destiny of all people
goes, "Whoa." You can't say that. You can't say they're not worthy
of moral consideration. That's crazy. [laughter] But he said
it multiple times. He's just straight up he like they he was
a part of the group that was laughing at Esports Batman when
Esports Batman asked Destiny why he was getting doxed, right?
Like these people don't realize that they are the explicit harassers.
They are the Kiwi farms.
It's it's them. What was the end of the clip? The end of the
clip was me saying that Mr. Moot is
the guy who would take the 20 mark bonus to pull the lever on
the gas chambers,
right? Like he would gas the explicitly just for the bonus. Like
he he's literally like, "Well, you guys did [__]
up our economy and you tried to ruin us in World War I, so
you're gassed now." Right? Just whatever whatever Gerbles said
was the propaganda,
you know. Oh, you're gassed now. Bye.
That's Mr. Moot. So, GG.
Anyway, I think that was the last clip there and then we go to
the next stream.
God, where is this?
I think we're on to the next stream, right? The one where we
get all the
This him ranting about his case. I want to do this whole section.
This whole section's a lot, man. Haven't they submitted anything
to discovery? What does the court do at that point? Um, I mean,
if they survive the motion to dismiss, now it's our turn to probably
start filing a bunch of motions on stuff. But I just I just like
talking about his court case the next day, one of these next
days.
So, he says, "Okay, well, if they don't file the motion to dismiss,
we have to file a whole bunch of stuff." >> Becomes how
much money do I want to spend filing motions? Like, >> becomes
how much money do we want to spend filing motions?
Didn't this guy oppose like Pixie getting the leaks taken down
from Kiwi Farms? Didn't he oppose like their request for a paper
limit increase, a page limit increase,
right? He literally opposed a motion to have extra pages on a
motion.
The most deranged.
I don't know how much that cost him. He was like, "No, Andy B,
write it up and submit it." Okay. The motion to to the motion
to oppose them asking for an additional page on their on their
Has he has Hasn't he been complaining about their motion spam?
Yes, he has. >> We would do like motions on spoliation
and everything because they've been deleting and hiding. And
now we know that for a fact after discovery um or after the deposition,
especially of Lauren de Laguna. Um they haven't turned over anything,
so we could file motions to compel. But Pixie's never turning
over anything cuz this is all a joke to her. I don't expect her
to. Like I have no conversation between her and Aaron. I have
no conversation between her and Lauren. I have no conversation
between her and basically anybody. So she just didn't turn over
anything.
Like I like call me crazy. I do feel
couldn't a court just say
oh um you're not going to turn over this thing while we think
you have this thing. Why why would a court just let him what's
the proof of expoliation? So he'll say that it is Lauren de Laguna
saying in a deposition she had like a 9-hour deposition or something.
I believe Lauren de Laguna said some like what was it? It was
oh I'm trying to think it was that her and Pixie talked via Signal
with autodeing messages right
and so he says that's expoliation.
Now I will argue that he has said a hundred different times that
Lauren de Laguna is not relevant to the case. She's not party
to the case. I don't know why if that was his belief he would
have thought that Lauren and Pixie have to save their chats.
I don't know if you didn't see it, but BB Poison gifted 25 subs.
I literally didn't see it. Uh, that I literally didn't see it
at all. Oh my god. What?
I didn't see that at all. Is that a real thing that happened?
No, he didn't give 25 subs. He subbed for 25 months. Thank you
very much for BB poison for the 25 months. That was 25 months,
not 25 subs.
Um, that's why I missed it because it was an individual sub and
I don't get the notification for those.
just it's the notifications pile up sometimes. So, if it's not
like a TTS, I I think I shut them off mostly or a set of gifted
subs. Also, when they talked Well, I don't think I do think it
was probably Has the court determined that to be expoliation?
No, he's saying they'd have to file a motion to to say they believe
it's spoilation because that is what Pixie team did was they
alleged spoliation without filing a motion um against that or
something. There's just there's like literally a motion you can
file to allege
Wait, are we How much time do we have? We got an hour left. Um,
we probably have like more time on this as well.
We can just go until we're done. We'll just go until we're done.
Lauren admitted to her uh and Pixie using uh Signal since the
very start of this case to autodelete every message. So, I mean
like yeah, they haven't produced Abby for a deposition. Like,
it's all just I'm serious. >> Is it on them to produce
Abby for a
Wouldn't you just have to serve Abby? But by the way, when he
was complaining about not having Abby for like a deposition,
they didn't they didn't subpoena her originally for a
right? They only produced as documentation evidence that they
subpoenaed her for what was it? Logs or something, I think, messages.
So, that's not that's not her failing to come to a deposition.
She wasn't summoned to that trial that um not trial, that uh
hearing they had. She wasn't like requested to be there by anyone.
Like, he keeps saying that, oh, they haven't produced her. for
them. I don't think they have to. I think she signs the thing
and then it's like in court
basically if they want to use that piece of evidence, right?
Which I understand that feels like a loophole. Um, and maybe
maybe there is an argument that for a motion to dismiss if that
person refuses to appear when subpoenaed to be deposed. if she
refuses to appear, it's possible that like I I do think it's
possible they consider that and consider not um
like not including that as a reason to provide subject matter
jurisdiction. See you, Kuryoko. Have a good one, buddy. >> Yeah,
I don't know. But I think the thing that'll hurt him the most
is on again on the motion to dismiss where they had the chance
to establish subject matter jurisdiction to say the court can
hear this case. They gave nothing. >> Marty Epste, thank
you for the five gifted. Let's go. Huge W. Massive. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you, Marty Epste.
literally
the the biggest Oiler. Okay. 15 subs, 10 of which came before
the intro screen was even finished. Thank you so much, Marty.
Appreciate it, man. All they did was try to they hired that weird
Jesus guy to try to nitpick at my evidence, but they did nothing
to affirmatively support their case, especially in response to
a motion to dismiss. Like, this is the easiest point for them
to affirmatively declare they have a case. They could submit
literally any evidence whatsoever. They could make [__]
up if they wanted. Um, but they submitted nothing. They could
make up if they wanted. I do believe that the Abbey thing gets
them through.
Like unless unless there's a reason to toss the Abbey deposition,
which I assume would have to be filed as a motion. I assume that
just gets them through. That's what every lawyer I've seen comment
on this say that like the Abby deposition just gets them through
this that that he has not provided like basically he said, "Well,
here's here's the DMs that I saved and it's not there." It's
like, well, I do believe that's something for a jury to decide
whether they think your your collecting of these DMs was effective.
I do think that is a jury like a like a jury issue,
but we'll see. Maybe they rule not. It's like I [__]
I'd say on that one, I'm probably like 30% leaning towards they
rule it a jury like a a jury issue. Like 10 to 15% they dismiss,
and then like whatever the rest is, 65% unknown, 55% unknown.
>> I don't know. Compelling Abby will help with the MSJ.
Yeah. I mean, I imagine we'll probably file that to compel. I
mean, she that's the only witness. She kind of has to. >> If
they haven't filed something to compel, then I don't see any
reason. If they haven't pushed the issue on that, I don't understand
why they're upset. Don't they ask Discord? Well, I don't know if
they've gotten actual subpoenas through to talk to Discord. I
have no idea. They'd have to subpoena Discord, and I don't know
if they did, and I don't know if Discord would have stuff retained,
so difficult to say. And yeah, I I do wonder like why wouldn't
they have filed the motion to compel Abby to for as long as he's
been about it on stream? Why would they have not filed the motion
to dismiss? In Destiny's own words, anything said in public that
isn't filed in something is a statement you shouldn't take seriously.
So, when he consistently complains about how Abby won't appear
for a deposition, if they haven't filed a motion to compel her
to appear, if they haven't filed a motion to press the issue,
I do wonder why we
uh un indeterminate ZZ sidewalk chalk. I a lot of people think
he just ran the guy over. I'd say probably leaning towards just
ran the guy over, but I wanted to run with the theory. >> Just
sit for a deposition, of course. But um I mean, if they I I don't
know if it'll even get that far. We'll see. Cuz I It's got to
look really bad that the only witness they have, they didn't
produce for deposition or depose >> So, that is just a
really stupid thing, isn't it? That they didn't depose this person
themselves. What Why would they need to depose them when they
have a sworn statement? uh not literally sworn but a statement
under penalty of perjury from the person. I don't know why they
would need anything else
>> or as a line of privacy and destroying evidence. Is
there even a line? In court cases, there's not really that line
at all. Your privacy is highly violated. I've turned over a lot
of personal intimate conversations to Pixie that she now has
access to. But >> so if I sue you, I can just see your
DM. >> I'm so glad that he's done talking about his personal
life. By the way, one day ago
guys, 2026 is the year we don't talk about the personal life
anymore. Okay? Only stream stuff, only politics or stream stuff.
All right? Not talk about the personal at all.
Next year, you're laughing, but unironically, yeah, that's one
of the reasons why civil suits can be so painful. A lot of the
stuff that you see that like is comes out from court cases and
stuff is people leaking stuff or stuff just coming out as a result
of discovery. It's an incredibly invasive process. Yes. This
is one of the things that I think um
I think one of the reasons why I was maybe discouraged from following
the suit as far as I have is because lawyers are realistic and
understand that their clients maybe lie or hide things from them
sometimes. I think every lawyer probably has that where it's
like I don't know if I but um no like all my is [__]
leaked. I have [__] nothing at all to hide at this
point. Like [__] me. So um yeah, I had no problem,
you know. Yeah, here have some conversations, go through it.
But um she's turned over basically nothing for good reason.
Wow.
Wow. Wow.
Destiny never. Never. He would never. Guys, I know this is like
the eighth year in a row I've had to give the speech about how
I know that these people said I was bad, but like I'm moving
on from toxic people. My I know this is like the eighth year
running. I've given the same speech about how I'm leaving all
the toxic people in the past and they all lied about me and it's
all going to be fine going forward. I know this is the eighth
year of the row, but this eighth year in a row, but this time
I really mean it. This time I really really laughing, but unironically,
yeah, that's one of the reasons why civil suits can be so painful.
A lot of the stuff that you see that like is comes out from court
cases and stuff is people leaking stuff or stuff just coming
out as a result of discovery. It's an incredibly invasive process.
Yes, >> this is one of the things that I think um
I think one of the reasons why I was maybe discouraged from following
the suit as far as I have is because lawyers
are realistic and understand that their clients maybe lie or
hide things from them sometimes. I think every lawyer probably
has that where it's like I don't know if my but um no
my lawyer signs off on all of my public >> like all my
is leaked. I have nothing at all to hide at this point like me.
So um yeah I had no problem you know. Yeah have some conversations
go through it but um she's turned over basically nothing for
a good reason.
Um hold on I'm trying to think of what
um sell this. So, Signal just deletes chats automatically. >> Nope,
it doesn't. You have to set it to do it, which she did, and she
admitted that under deposition. So, >> I didn't know that.
>> Again, I thought she wasn't related, but
I guess the absence of evidence here. I'm glad that Destiny's
just come to all of my positions as well. Like I would argue
that Abby with her contempor contemporaneous messages basically
means that if Destiny's the only source of those DMs that probably
like you need some other source that him deleting them uh trying
to clear all that out before anything had gone through. I thought
that was quite bad. Right. But now he's he's agreeing basically.
He's agreeing. Hey, you it's your job to keep all of this there
on that platform. It's your job. Your job your burden.
>> What if she turned over Pixie?
>> I guess he's arguing. You could argue he means that
they should download it as well. Um,
again, just that she's not related. So, no. Dude, his own arguments
come back to bite him on this. How did he argue for so long that
she's
Why do you like this guy again? Um,
honestly, like a lot of the drama content when the when the breakup
with Max happened, I didn't think Max was like that bad a person.
I thought they were both like kind of bad people. I never really
bought the hit job on Max. Like I could I could kind of just
see that like I was like I I guess I kind of get like why he's
going after Max. He feels like violated personally. But I didn't
see Max as like a bad guy. So Max is somebody who maybe like
misinterpreted some evidence. And then I found out that Max didn't
really misinterpret at all. He kind of just had although he didn't
have the evidence. He I guess soul read this guy. That's like
the only other way to put it, right? Like Max was just Max just
like nailed this guy from like the the the jump. So,
um, but I it was like the Max Abba Lav
low tier god Anna uh was it like black Anna? The [__]
was that black girl's name? Not Anastasia Analicia. Like all
of those all of that content was great. Uh, no. Max was psychopathic.
Max insisted that it was one way and it wasn't. It absolutely
was that way. The pattern Max prescribed or described was totally
true, completely correct. Um, he did not have people who were
willing to stand with him on that. Anavore came out like two
years later on my stream and basically backed up all of the things
Max actually asserted that Destiny said, "Oh, well, you don't
have any proof of
Anavore literally came out and said that that was all correct.
What Max said was correct. Um, the entire thing he did there,
if you bought that, Kger, that was him muddying the waters in
the same way he's doing now. Um, I'm not I'm not even saying
Max is like a good person, although I don't think he's like an
evil person. I I don't personally, but I don't need you to like
Max or think he's a good person. I'm saying that with regards
to Destiny, he was correct in his descriptions of Destiny. 100%
Um, and then he just didn't have enough evidence to show it.
Yeah. I like I again, if you want to argue, we could go read
like the first couple paragraphs of that article. I'll argue
the read was correct, right? His thesis was correct and then
his evidence was not enough to put together.
I think Max is an evil person. I'll stand on that. Even outside
of the actions with Destiny. Okay. Well, luckily I didn't say
Max was a good person. I just said he so read Destiny and totally
perfectly described him possibly. Listen, maybe I have a bad
read on Max. And the reason he sold read Destiny perfectly is
because he saw something similar in Destiny was able to like
just project his own mindset onto Destiny. But he did he did
soul read him. He did have him totally 100%
But like, by the way, I I'll say again, I don't think Max is
like evil or something. I don't think so. I I totally I don't
think that. But I'm willing to say that I could be wrong on that.
And maybe like maybe I just have a bad read on him. Clearly had
a bad read on Destiny. Although I don't know if I describe Destiny
as evil. He's just not somebody who gives moral consideration
to other people like in in his own like in how he treats them.
There's nothing there. Pixie basically just went through a whole
bunch of messages on Discord and anything that mentioned or no
it was a couple mentions of my name. So I've got like ex
>> Did Anavore Anavor literally presented the DMs? We've
gone over them multiple times on stream accelerate of her basically
being like, "I really hate it that your community calls me a
stalker." And he's like, "Well, I'll fix your reputation later.
For now, just let me like rub your legs and feet,
right?" The explicit like the explicit, "Hey,
um, let me have like some kind of thing with you." He's a foot
fetish. Let me have some kind of thing with you and then after
that we will maybe look at fixing your reputation.
Very gross. Very weird.
right? While while presenting to the public and he threatened
to leak her nudes to prevent her from leaking these DMs at the
time. If she'd leaked these DMs at the time, it would have gone
really badly for him, right? Cuz she was basically saying, "You're
calling me crazy, but we talk like often." And he went, "No,
no, you're crazy. And if you leak anything about me, you leak
any of my I'll leak some pictures of you. I got some pictures
of you that I'm going to
Like, dude,
it's crazy. I don't really care to argue the whole thing on on
Max's reputation. I'm not concerned about um I'm not concerned
about Max's reputation. As far as I can tell, it seems like Max
and his girlfriend are pretty happy now that they've basically
exited this space totally.
And
I tend to lean towards the stuff with the girlfriend was art.
uh maybe we see it differently. It's like art.
It's like the whole bit thing. I don't really want to go through
the Max stuff to be honest with you. I just say that for whatever
reason. Maybe, maybe it's because he's evil. Maybe it's because
he's insightful. Maybe it's because he's schizophrenic and he
is a mon he's the 10,000th monkey who got the script perfect.
I don't know what the reason is, right? I literally don't know
what the reason is that Max was able to soul read Destiny so
perfectly, but he did. That's really that's really all we have
to talk. It's all we have to acknowledge. It's fine. Okay, maybe
tourn entirely possible. I don't know. I don't really remember
the content excerpts from some conversations and then I would
say probably 70 to 80% of the discovery they turned over to me
was just a giant group chat that all six of us were in for like
planning events in Miami and and that was it. Otherwise, I have
no full conversation between her and anybody.
What happens if you're not submitting anything? Does she just
get to do whatever? Well, I mean, we would file a motion for
uh to compel. We'd file a motion for adversarial reading. I don't
know what that you and I are talking cross each other. I meant
what caused Max to blow up originally with Destiny refusing to
defend him on the subreddit. Wait, hold on, Creator. You'd have
to admit that then Destiny's like now Max, right? Destiny is
Max in the Pisco context except he's still the bigger creator,
right?
We all understand that that that's Destiny's core criticism right
now is that he wants other people to either defend him or give
him the ability to defend himself. Like he he's bas Max is actually
less crit was like just give me the ability to defend myself.
Don't like moderate my people out. Right? If Pis could you imagine
if Pisco was taking people who were defending Destiny as chat
and moderating them out, could you imagine how nuclear Destiny
would go? Like he would go totally nuclear. He is just doing
the Max thing but on like a mass scale. He's done it with my
community. He's doing it to to Pisco's community
and everybody just everybody just lives under this like Paul
all of the time, this cloud where they know they say something
bad about Destiny. They're going to have to deal with their audience
who love this guy like losing their on him. They all know it,
right? And so they all just like avoid it. They they get out
of it. And I don't have like condemnation for those people. I
get it. You want to keep doing your job. This is how you make
your money. It's like not worth it to stand on this, right? It's
just not worth it. I get it. I get that it's the correct decision,
but like that's what's happening here is these people are all
just being bullied and they're just going, yeah, I get it. It's
like, oh man, it it is kind of just like the Trump thing, right?
Like a whole bunch of people are just like, well, we'll go along
to get along and then this guy will be gone eventually and things
just keep getting worse. Motion is technically, but basically
or maybe just a spilation saying like, hey, they didn't produce
anything because they've hid or destroyed evidence, so the jury
is allowed to look at this disfavorably.
Um, but like the question is like, do I want to do this? Because
every time, you know, motions just they cost money. Motion practice
costs money and then they're gonna cross motion. >> Dude,
did Max did Max say something crazy? I'm trying to think like
ma Max is like more reasonable in the moderation request than
Destiny is to Pisco, is he not? Destiny doesn't even think about
what he's going to ask for from Pisco before he starts talking
about Pisco in his community. Like Max actually had some thoughts
on what he wanted for moderation and then he went with those
exact thoughts and said this is what I want is that Destiny is
just talking about how Pisco doesn't moderate his community and
then lying about Pisco. He's not saying here's how you should
moderate it. Pisco said how should I moderate it? He goes, "Man,
I don't even want to talk to you about it." Man, I don't even
know. You just do whatever you want to do. Yeah, I think I think
Destiny's request was to or sorry, Max's request was totally
reasonable.
I think Max, the only thing unreasonable about the way Max did
that was making it a big thing on stream,
right? That's the only thing that I thought was unreasonable.
But then I interacted with Destiny and realized that unless you
make things a thing on stream, he's going to ignore you like
90% of the time, right? You basically have to make it if you
want address, you have to make it content on stream to some extent.
Yeah. I think his point is that he's attracting certain kinds
of people by saying by what he's saying.
No, that's not Hold on. His main complaint is about the what's
his main complaint about the type of people Sophie King? It's
people like Dubie. Dubbie was his number one complaint, wasn't
it? Doobie, Jtock, Doobie, Jtock, Queman. What do these people
have in common? They don't like Destiny. It's not, oh, they're
really crazy about everything. It's not No. The a thing that
links all of us is we just don't like Destiny. And we are a able
to articulate what's wrong with the way Destiny talks, with what
he does, right?
So, when he says, "Oh, it's about the people you're attracting."
That's just a way of being avoidant.
He doesn't like. And when these people actually get down to providing
examples, it's it's, "Oh, well, Doobie spent $1,000 just posting
things about me." Okay, which one of those things was false?
Which one of the things that Doobie posted was false? I think
spending the money is crazy, but I don't think anything he said
was crazy. He framed that as Pisco saying, "Why are you reading
voice? You just want me to start banning people?" I mean, that's
what he's asking for. That's explicitly what he's asking for.
Like I h it's too bad that the reputation assassination stuff
just works so well on all of these people. Like I I feel like
it does.
I don't know. Maybe I'll show up on a Pisco stream at some point
and just be like, "Hey, this is how I feel like it's going and
here's why I feel like you get attacked
and I understand why maybe you don't want to litigate it." And
that's okay.
But I do feel like it's really unreasonable. And I do feel like
I do feel like there's been like some reputation assassination
that I suffered in a similar way to the way you've suffered it.
And
are you and Pisco cool? Um, well, I've never talked to him. I
don't get a chance I don't get a chance to talk to him at all.
He doesn't respond to anything I've said to him. He doesn't I
I like as far as I know, I might be sitting in a message queue
or something somewhere.
Um,
Pisco will understand. Pisco understands perfectly. Pisco understands
perfectly. I think it's not good for Pisco to associate with
me in any case. So, I have to like kind of let that go. And it
sucks cuz it's like
I basically have to say, well, I understand that he wants to
go and do his thing and that would probably like
be he would talk to me, but I think he would have to there's
always this like Paul that hangs over the conversation, right?
that if you if I were to talk to him, he would go, "Okay, like
this this this
and it would be like bad for him unless he was going like hard
on me,
I think any conversation where like we had a where where we had
like a nice conversation would end up being an economic harm
to him.
So, I don't know. It's difficult for me to talk to him, right?
Like basically he is economically incentivized to dislike me
or to like try to press me on things in like a general sense.
Uh and he also it's possible he also just doesn't like me. That's
that that's possible. Very possible really.
Um pretty black pilling seeing so many people be stupid enough
to fall for this. I don't know if it's blackpilling for me anymore.
I think I just need to take more steps back to like macro analyze
the situation. I get way too like into it and then reactive instead
of just like stepping back. Like the way you want to handle building
a channel or even having opinions on the internet is you want
to take time to sit down, write out your thoughts, come up with
something and then move forward with it. You shouldn't ever just
be reacting from like dayto day and like doing things from day
to day. You should have an explicit plan about how you want to
carry things forward into the future and then be like if things
go bad in any given moment, you need to be able to stick to something.
you need to have some bedrock that you're going to stick to and
keep moving with. And I think for a little while, the past like
maybe 3, four months, I've been more like the reactive type instead
of just sitting down and like calculating out how I think things
should go and then imposing that. Like I've been getting blown
around like the ship in the ocean,
but I'm totally capable of and have both with the streaming thing
and other places in my career. It's like I'm just going to sit
down and write out the way things are and then I'm going to impose
that on the world. Never thought of putting it into a proper
detailed video. Um, well, I don't really have a platform for
it. That's the issue. But possibly, we'll see. A lot of lot of
things coming up. A lot of things cooking, I think. But like
actually starting to do things actually. Hold on. No, not a lot
of things cooking.
Not yet.
But they are. Trust me, I'm at the point where it's um
it's gonna start happening. Okay. All
Okay. Where are we going from here? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No,
that's why I just I I backed up Gummy Vers and I'm like, "No,
no, no. Things aren't cooking." But things will be, trust me.
You say you got your YouTube back. Kind of. Yeah. Kind of. Yes.
We'll see.
To whatever us and then we have to reply and respond and all
this. So,
but um yeah, I mean, I don't think I I don't even know what they
want to do. I I I doubt they actually want to sit at trial. I
don't know. Unless it's she doesn't mind the humiliation of that
because she thinks she's a waste of my money. So, who knows?
How is it they can do pretty much anything and you just get over?
Um I mean, I would argue because of an asymmetry of um
reputation and power at this point since I have more to lose,
she has more to um me over with. Okay, hold on. What do we
Let me learn this blueprint, I guess.
>> Page five is just a giant goalie skin. Oh,
it only costs simple gun parts to make heavy gun parts. >> Let
me let me shut up. Shut up. Okay, let me see where these clips
are cuz I might want to skip through here.
>> Oh, these are not Damn it. Hold on. >> Like stamps
here, but I don't >> 1 hour 13. >> Huge. So, when
I get my >> I thought it's going to be >> Shut up.
That was number three. Okay, there's more to this segment. I
just need to make sure this isn't in the middle. Oh, that's way
off somewhere >> against here. >> No, I don't think
I don't know if I can sue her for anything. >> So, after
Lauren's license, um, I'll submit a formal bar complaint in regards
to her behavior in this case. Um, like knowingly deleting evidence
and everything and then the attempt to I think briber. >> Could
that I mean, it could probably be successful. It's probably just
like anything, right? It's probably like a call to CPS or trying
to report like aite to the Canadian government or something.
It's probably just like these things where it's like, well, it
won't be successful probably. Um, there is always the chance
that the administration doesn't look at things like correctly.
They make a mistake. It's like inconveniencing somebody in a
totally unreasonable way. I don't know why he would say he wants
to submit a bar complaint and that she's unrelated to she he
said she's unrelated to the case a thousand times.
I don't know why he would submit a bar complaint because she
didn't want her messages saved.
But I I guess he if he feels like Lauren de Laguna is that three
a
three ellipsis person on Kiwi Farms >> for mom um to get
her to help uh Ixy's
>> Uh this was a this is referring to the Sunday thing
where I think Sunday was looking at reporting aite or something
over some credential thing way back in the day.
I'm not saying to do that obviously. I'm just referencing some
drama where it's like you're inconveniencing somebody in real
life and and sometimes the the reason for doing that is like
oh well there's no downside right by the way food jobs is spinning
a narrative that you are conspiring with Pisco probably talking
points given to them by Destiny.
I mean I joke about it. Pisco doesn't talk to me. I here I'll
I'll open up my Pisco DMs right now. I'm not going to leak them
but I'll just read. Um,
the first
um,
the first thing I sent, okay, it's like unrelated. It was about
a troll in his chat that I don't want to out. Okay, I'll do it
because I don't want to actually leave anything out. I warned
him that the the dickers that was in his chat was actually Kosher
Kathy, but I didn't say kosher Kathy. I was like, "That's a troll.
You probably shouldn't talk to that person because they're just
going to try to [__] with you." Okay. So, I snitched
on kosher Kathy. I confess I confess one time in July of 2025,
I snitched on Kosher Kathy. Okay, one time
and I think Kathy got on anyway, so I don't think it matters.
Okay, I was not I I thought Kathy was kind of just like a total
Kathy is kind of crazy, but it's fine. Um, the other one was
a clip. So then from July 27th is when I sent that. July 29th,
I sent a clip of this, which was Straight Raid explaining her
position on communism.
>> Now with Adam Cherry. Oh, are you a
>> so it was like ch it was a straight raid straighter
raid explaining her position on communism during that that thing
and I said watch the full clip um three and a half minutes and
you'll be vindicated on this and I got no response. And then
on July 31st I said sorry you're getting from some perceived
and essentially non-existent association to me or you're getting
for some perceived and essentially non-existent association to
me. Dude, I don't think I've argued anything in regards to this
in bad faith. I'm enjoying politics content again thanks to you
and the live and learn guys.
No response. Those are the three messages I've sent. The dickers
Kathy did get on. So, I didn't even he didn't even read it. Okay,
we didn't we couldn't even present that. That was how I felt.
I felt like literally anytime I'd watch politics content, I just
think about this disgusting loser and it was like kind of
and then I was like, "Oh, but I'm enjoying watching live and
learn sometimes, watching like some actual discussion happen.
pretty good. Pretty good. So, I just I was like, "Hey, I'm sorry
that you're getting um That was in July, by the way. I'm sorry
you're getting like for some perceived association to me." I
just I like the way Pisco argues. I like the way he sets up arguments.
It's probably evident in the fact that like when I'm watching
him, I can explain what he's trying to argue to people really
easily. No, this was not backhanded. It was uh I wouldn't say
I wouldn't say the Live and Learn guys anymore. This was when
Josiah was on. And I like Josiah. So I wouldn't say the Live
and Learn guys anymore because yes, it would be kind of disingenuous
now that I don't really Soy pills may be okay. I'm not a huge
fan of IRI or Hutch
but um listen, the snitching on Kathy didn't even work. So anyway,
why not I is cool. Um
I just think he's a shill. I think like
I don't think he really ar I think he's like a character. It
just makes me feel when I engage with him, right? He's like,
I had an argument with him about Biden and why they should drop
Biden in January of 2023, I think. And he was like, "No, man.
Biden's awesome. Biden's like the sharpest he's ever been."
And he's the guy who does politics full-time. I was just the
guy who was there like, "I think this guy's really old and you're
going to lose if you run him as a candidate." Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And then Son came in was like, "Hey, did you
off?" I was like, "Okay, well, bye. Guess they don't want my
opinion.
Guess they don't want the opinion of a
And for our next guest, we're going to bring Nazu Aerodite onto
the stream. God damn it. Anyway. Anyway.
>> Okay. Her green card illegally. Okay. What am I looking
for? Okay. >> Wait, what did he say about Pixie's wife
or whatever >> in regards to her behavior in this case?
Um, like knowingly deleting evidence and everything. And then
the attempt to I think bribe her mom um to get her to help uh
Pixie's wife on her green card >> What?
And whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. What?
What? What? What? Wait, whose mom?
Pixie's mom. >> Regards to her behavior in this case. Um,
like knowingly deleting evidence and everything. And then the
attempt to I think bribe her mom um to get her to help uh Pixie's
wife on >> Oh, maybe Lauren's mom. >> You can ask
her judge. But >> wait, wait. Oh, did Lauren say this that
like, hey, we were basically talking about something to for the
green card thing and he knows that's the reason they the deleted
messages and he's just trying to paint a narrative. Oh. Uhoh.
>> Have to be a jury trial or can it be
>> Going ice fishing with Uncle Buster and Cousin Gordy
next week. Any stompers you recommend? Been looking at them Blundstone
blies. They real nice.
Um, I actually have a really awesome pair, but they're for Canada
and
oh man, I forget what they're called. Oh, hold on. I'll go grab
them. Just give me a second. Give me like two seconds. I'm going
to leave you guys on silence.
Okay, I'm back. All right,
they're muck boots from the Muk Boot Company. The original Muk
Boot Company. These things are awesome. They're perfect for ice
fishing. I'm sure they'd be perfect for whatever the [__]
you're doing out in the bayou out there. Okay, Bubba Ray McCoy.
They're like the best. They're like winter boots mixed with rubber
boots. Water never gets through them. Okay. They're like the
best thing that exists in the whole world. Good luck. >> Judge
trial. But I think the plaintiff in this case requested a jury
trial. And you always have a right to a jury trial, so you can
request it. >> I thought the case is going to be against
Laguna. No, I don't think I don't know if I can sue her for anything.
So after Lauren's license, um, I'll submit a formal bar complaint
in regards to her behavior. >> Oh, sorry, I'm on the wrong
video. Hey, >> No, I'm not. Wait, why did I go back that
far? Wait, what? >> In this case, um like knowingly deleting
evidence and everything and then the attempt to I think bribe
her mom. Oh. Um
>> that's the Okay, Lauren attempted to bribe her mom and
that's how he's going to go after her with the bark plate >> to
get her to help uh ex's wife on her green card illegally. Okay,
what am I looking for? Okay, I still need that sentinel for car.
If you lose your bar in, let's say, like Arizona,
I assume that you would have to put that if you went ever wanted
to get like a bar in California, right? >> Um, yeah, generally
you're only you can be I think there's two ways kind of >> just
say probably, but you don't know. Please just say probably, but
you don't know. That sounds reasonable, but I don't know. >> You
can either get licensed to practice in a particular state by
taking their bar. There's also something called, I think, the
UB, the universal bar exam that applies to like 30 or 40 states.
So, you could do that, but if your bar um if your license gets
restricted or gets um sanctioned
>> taken in one state, I think it'll automatically resend
them in all of them. Like I don't think you can be restricted
to practice or whatever. Yeah. But you also you don't have to
be licensed to practice in every state. What you can do is so
like in my current court case, I have my the lead council on
my case is the Breler Law Firm and but they are not I don't think
any of them are licensed. I don't call me so I don't think they're
licensed to practice in Florida. What you do is you get a local
council in Florida and then you can get the other people to appear
as like co-consel. So they fire the the motion for proh Vich
is basically saying can I make an appearance from another district
or from another jurisdiction or >> and then they kind of
just sit there and
>> Do you think that those chances are better with a jury
versus a bench trial? I don't I don't think she has a good chance
on any trial. It all of it looks just so horrible. And as much
as people I've said this million times as much as people want
to meme on me it's like oh they're going to see you as a and
blah blah blah. They're not. They're just going to see a girl
who is sending nude videos or videos of her, her boyfriend, me
and my girlfriend to each other and then recording something
and then freaking out that whether even if she didn't want it
to get leaked, like I don't think a jury is going to have much
sympathy there that we still >> I'm sorry. I
I think I think this is the biggest cope I've ever seen in my
entire life.
All all that will need to be said is like the name Destiny that
these people will go home and Google.
>> live in a separate country like it's not it's yeah it's
not I don't think so. >> Selection could be memes.
>> I mean I guess >> not that we want to get there
but
>> I don't even know how that goes for civil trial. Okay.
46. >> Uh this is a girl. [laughter]
I don't think we want them.
>> Dang girl. Okay. Um, okay. Where you want to go?
>> Yeah, we're going to host graveyard.
>> I'm bringing one level two anvil. Do you like the silencer?
>> I never um I'll use it. I have nothing >> Probably
better to have a compressor. >> Not even that funny ride.
Not even for sure. You understand what the dispersion does, right?
>> Sorry, I just went through more court
>> Uh, narrower. Is that the word? [__] liar
circular by the way
>> or not. And then the um that any factual
>> how why would your character matter with respect to
what the jury has to determine for count one? Your character
always matters whether you wanted to or not. And then the um
[snorts] um for count one, which is really the only count really
at play in my entire court case. The other three are um it comes
down to whether or not we agreed to share videos with anybody
else. And that's what the jury would have to make a factual determination
on. and Pixie's credibility and the credibility of the people
around her. >> That's I think he's totally deliluding himself
here. And Lonerbox has explained exactly why this argument is
insane. And that's probably why they had to depose Rose. And
it's probably why the Rose stuff makes a lot of sense to have
on the record because he knew Rose for 7 days. He thought she
was 18. An
worker. She knew or sorry, he knew for seven days. Okay. The
idea that Pixie by saying, "Oh, well, I don't mind if Molina
sees this stuff." is also consenting to you sending the video
to that person. He's basically arguing that he can make that
argument in court,
Isn't that that's obviously insane. No,
>> that seems like obviously obviously insane to me. >> Uh
ADHD runs me 619. Thank you very much for the five gifted. Let's
go. Uh I'm I'm adding like more time here. I just I'll just literally
add it here. I'm probably adding more time than this damage or
whatever this is. Um, and my credibility based on all the filings
I I would imagine is pretty high. So,
um, yeah, I don't know. >> But he says, "Your credibility
matters a lot." And then he's like he also thinks I wonder if
he also thinks the juries don't go and like look up who the person
>> What am I looking for? >> But I think that's also
why he hired Bretler, right? I think he hired Bretler because
he wants to I think that's a big thing is they want to show that
like the online reputation
I know they're not supposed to. I think that's a part of Breler's
whole thing is showing that he can make it so your online reputation
looks like squeaky clean, right?
No. No. Andrew Breler really does do this. Like that's really
a thing. Yo, Venomous Villain, thank you for the 2,000 kicks.
Let's go.
Let's go. Yeah. Well, I don't think anybody really follows that
instruction. and legit just came. I think I think people hear
that and they probably go, I'm going to go look this guy up.
I'm an American. You can't tell me what to do.
>> Okay. Which, hey, that's unfair. That's bringing things
in from outside of the trial. I just think basically, if he's
counting on his reputation to save him, I don't know that that's
smart. Um, if the trial is only a couple days, I can see that.
I understand perfectly well they're not supposed to. I do know
that. I do know that. I do know that. I think basically people
will tell you not to go to trial explicitly because a lot of
things from outside of the case can become relevant that you
don't want to be relevant. Yeah, that is how you get out of jury
duty 100%.
You ever get called for a case like this? Okay, what am I looking
for here? I'm looking for either more time stamps. I got to get
through this faster. >> I'm saying the data transmission
factual dispute can go all the way to trial.
Oh,
the well the only the my understanding is at this point I think
the all the row stuff is going to be completely tossed which
is a huge problem for them because the only thing that would
come up would basically be Abby and you know like I've said I
went through all my messages with Abby. I've never sent her any
video ever. So you have to imagine that the whole trial is going
to be Abby on the stand testifying that I sent her videos that
I know I didn't send her. Right now the jury doesn't know that.
Right? But
>> it's going to be >> have to get Abby to come.
>> Yeah. Well, she'll have she'd have to be a trial. Yeah,
>> she would have to be a trial. >> Um so it's going
to be Abby on the stand explaining how I sent her videos. She's
going to have to explain how one video because she claims I also
sent her videos of me and Cherry. Those videos don't exist. I've
never taken videos like that before. Unless Cherry did. Um so
that's impossible. So half of that message is just not true.
And then she's going to have to explain.
Abby said that the video that he got that she was sent of Cherry
was shouldn't have been brought into the case, but she said that
it was audio only, that it was like a black screen, which I'm
sorry, but like that just an audio file. Good. And how she didn't
just see these videos on my computer when she was at my house
going through my computer on phone with Darius talking about
it. >> I would just wonder like basically the the way they're
going to present it from the other side is how did this person
who you say is like crazy, how did they have a 100% guess rate?
They didn't say anything about other people, right? They didn't
say, "Oh, he sent me videos of like X, Y, Z, like ABC, B, C,
and D,
Why is this person who you say is like crazy and shouldn't be
trusted?" Why did she like a year before or two years before
have a 100% hit rate and sink your battleship here? Why did that
happen
would be like my question,
right? And all the other private pictures she took in my house
and sent to other people. Um, she's going to have to explain
why she has no evidence at all of me sending her that video and
why none of it was provided. Um, yeah, that's it's just it's
yeah, that's a
His answer is she snooped on his PC. Does he have any evidence
of that? I Does she have any evidence of that? The Darius text
the Darius text is not proof of that at all. If the Darius text
were proof of that, anything more than her just looking at that
screen, why would that evidence not be here? That would be the
question. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But like, if it wasn't a joke, then
don't you just get the rest of those texts and show them? Why
have none of the rest of the texts been shown? I don't know.
I'm literally never talking about that, Accelerate. Don't ask
me that ever again. Thank you. Not Not like it's whatever, but
I'm never talking about that ever. So, I mean, it's not impossible.
Like, anything theoretically can happen with a jury, but like
I don't know. I don't I feel good with my chances there. Um,
and then also you have to consider even let's assume that they
won on somehow that the jury believes Abby and all of that. >> Then
there's going to be a question of I don't even know what damages
Pixie would be able to bring when she
>> this this guy tried to help you. I tried to help you.
This Maximus guy tried to help you, Stinky Baconator, but he
couldn't help. >> Talks about um how damaged she is
>> because with the Rose stuff thrown out, I don't know
if you can tie my video transmission to Abby. I don't know if
you could tie that to any of the public
because um
it's not because Solo didn't grab anything from her. So I don't
even know how they would do damages at that point or what that
what would even be on the table for that. So it's just yeah all
of it like >> I missed what he said with the Rose stuff
thrown out. I don't know if you can tie my video transmission
to Abby. I don't know if you could tie that to any of the public
leaks
because um wait, is he hypothesizing that if he did get tied
to Abby then it wouldn't be his fault that it leaked? Why is
he hypothesizing that? I I just missed something critical. Why
is he even if you could pro
>> But it's not about um how damaged she is because with
the Rose stuff thrown out, I don't know if you can tie my video
transmission to Abby. I don't know if you could tie that to any
of the public
because um
it's not because Solo didn't grab anything from her. So I don't
even know how they would do damages at that point or what that
what would even be on the table for that. So it's just yeah all
of it like at in terms of like the legal again it's not >> that
is like an interesting question that like cuz he's saying the
Rose stuff thrown out. What he means is like obviously the Rose
stuff is before Cardi. Can you include the damage incurred from
the Rose stuff? I guess it just depends on um like vicarious
liability, right?
Like literally
he put this in somebody else's hand so that it could be leaked
later. How much is he responsible? That's Oh man, that's interesting.
Would law enforcement need to bring the rose stuff forth separate?
Yeah, this is a civil case. The rose stuff would be criminal
stuff. >> I mean, I haven't been worried about the legal
thing from almost day one. How stupid this has all been. But
um it's just a PR money investment in the legal proceedings.
Okay.
Do you feel you turned over too much? Um, no. I fulfilled all
my obligations. It's cringe and annoying, but listen, my spirit
animal yesterday, Hunter Biden, I've released everything. What
are you going to do?
How's Biden doing? >> Hunter, he seems like he's doing
okay.
What am I looking for? Refiner. >> Do you think he'd be
a good candidate to
>> Okay, cuz when I said that earlier, everybody in chat
was real bad. >> Well, stop being a dick. I need rubber.
>> Is that not right? is what not right? Um, so I don't
know how that would work in terms of damages when if he's found
guilty of the thing, can he only be found guilty of each count
individually? Like each sharing? Would they all be different
counts? Like if they found other ones? And then if they find
him like not guilty, but liable, they find him liable for the
Abbeby one, then could he be liable for the damages in that he
obviously had
some share of
right? like he had some share of the damages from Solo by virtue
of of sharing it, but
but like it's explicitly outside of the statute when he shared
it. So, I don't know how that works. I also think they haven't
determined exactly how not liable he is for that in terms of
making available. Again, I don't think that argument is good.
I don't think that's like something that's going to go against
him, the making available, the the what do you call it? Continuous
uh publishing thing. I don't know if it's going to work against
him. If it's proven he sent Pixie video to Abby after Cardi,
it's still illegal. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He's saying he's saying
that the damages what he's saying is there would be some amount
of damages that he would get hit for. Um Right. He would get
hit for damages on only the things that he's found liable for.
He can't be found liable for the Rose thing. Right. If he's if
he's saying that's all thrown out, then he feels like he can't
be held liable for those leaks. So that's where all of the damages
are coming from, right? In terms of the actual damages, it's
from the reputational harm of the Rose Leaks, which happened
before Cardi. So, how much of on the line would he be for damages
with respect to just the Abbey thing, which is not a whole lot,
right? Pixie doesn't have to prove damages for Cardi. I know
there's a statutory element for Cardi. It's not all statutory,
is it? I know there's a statutory amount that can be like maxed
out and he could still lose on the statuto amount. I'm talking
about the actual damages he'd be held accountable for as well.
And I just don't know if the actual damages would be there. It's
150k. I would assume per sharing of the video, Ally. So, it's
150k no matter what, right? I don't think it's I don't think
it's 150k penalty no matter what. I'm guessing that's the maximum
of the statutory damages. I'm guessing there's a minimum that
would be significantly lower because realistically, if you're
going to charge 150k to some like total deadbeat scumbag, it's
like doesn't even make sense, right?
But I think probably I've never I've never had any real particular
hope that the Rose stuff was going to be something that he could
be charged under Cardi for. I thought it was going to come down
to Discovery and if you can find another instance and then Abby
talked about it years ago or whatever, right?
They can't find other instances then like tough to I guess you
can't just charge him because he's I like I think he's obviously
guilty of sharing a whole bunch of people's [__]
without consent. It could be possible maybe that he's only oh
the peach logs as well. Oh yeah. I wonder if they'll present
those in court
like oh
the person who testified on his behalf is this peach person but
she also has said these things. I do think probably shouldn't
they be deposing Peach at the same time? Shouldn't Baby Peach
be taking the stand? Why haven't they subpoenaed [laughter] Baby
Peach?
I think those Peach leaks like I don't know how seriously you
take them but they're pretty bad, aren't they? I think they can't
force her, can they? Um, I think they can subpena her, but I
don't know how much power they have. I think they have to travel
to her.
>> can I help you?
>> Is it not funny how she claimed Oh, I didn't even know
that she did that. She confirmed the logs when they came out,
but now she claims they're fake. Oh, well, she's confirmed the
logs multiple times. There'd be like literally video evidence
on stream of her confirming those logs. I'm pretty confident
she's confirmed those logs are real multiple
What should we spell on the case so far? Um, I'll probably include
a write up at the very end of everything. I don't really It's
It's annoying talking about or complaining about any of the costs
associated with it because now everybody shifted so much to now
the whole W is just like, well, if I spend any money, that's
a win. So, every motion is a win for Pixie.
So, like I understand how he thinks this is. I don't really want
him just torn down monetarily because of whatever. I don't I
don't think that's appropriate. I like but when he originally
was talking about settling or not, he was like, "I'll pay whatever.
I don't want her to get a dime." I'm like, "Oh, that's really
stupid. That's like the that's like the dumbest attitude to have,
right?
That is such a dumb attitude to have because realistically, like
when she demands a certain amount of money, some of that amount
of money is factoring in the cost for like your legal team and
your legal fees and all the time it will take, right? She's saying,
"You're paying me to go away without seeking justice. here's
what it would cost you to like to deny me justice. That has to
factor into your decision. Right? So, when Destiny offers back
as his only offer I believe he made before they ended up filing
the case, I believe the only offer he made back was I'll let
you keep the subst
money and you have to apologize for the substack and take it
down. I think that's the only counter offer he gave. Now, for
me personally, that seemed really, really, really low, which
was the argument I made at the time. Hey, that argument is really
insulting because you'd have to go through and like agree to
pay out. You'd have to go through and litigate this whole thing.
It's going to cost you a ton of money. Like you should probably
just pay a certain amount of money out to like go ahead and avoid
the case, right? I think everything is a win for everybody. And
so if I complain about the money, they're like, "Oh, well actually
even though she knows she's losing and she knows it's all bull
and she knows it's all a lie." It's actually still super based
because she's wasting his money. So I was like, "Okay." >> Yeah.
I try not to revel in this just because I think it's pretty rough.
I try not to revel in it. I do think this person's terrible and
they've obviously caused a lot of harm to people I care about
and like me explicitly,
but I try not to just revel in the harm to them because I think
that's probably something that chips away at your soul over the
long term. But I do think that for his initial like response
to the 50 million thing for him to say, "Oh, it's only this,
right?" uh he likes to jump back to the initial 50 million ask,
but before they open the case against him, Pixie's lawyer asked
him to make an offer above 150K. An offer above Yeah. So that's
what I heard as well. Tomorrow's Joe was basically they were
like, "Hey, just make us an offer um that feels like respectable
and fair and we can like just move forward without this."
But he presents it as just the 15 million. and then like they
filed the case, but he gave a response back of apologize, retract
the substack, keep the keep just your um GoFundMe money, and
he wouldn't go to 150K,
but he always represents it as the 15 million thing. Yeah. A
serious offer over six figures. Yeah. So, like it's but there
just wasn't a serious offer made.
So, I don't know. Like I my argument at the time was where did
the 15 million probably that they had 15 million who came to
her and
like realistically you just ask for the moon when you're filing
the case or you're giving like the first offer, right? No, no,
no. Nobody actually expected 15 million. Nobody, not Destiny,
not Pixie's lawyers, not Pixie. Nobody expected 15 million. Nobody
thought he was going to go, "Okay, 15 million." They they literally
were like, "Oh, actually just make us a serious offer above 150
or something." Then why say it? Because that's how you open negotiations
for any court case is you just shoot for the moon. You literally
say this is our like literally without talking to us at all,
you could end this all for this much money, right? It's literally
it's it's just it's literally just hey
this is what I would get in my dreams.
I hope she gets the full 50 million. She can't get the full 50
million. I don't think that's like uh possible.
Um, I don't think it's insane as like, oh, this is my my super
ideal in the best case scenario. I just get this much money.
I don't think it's like crazy in those ways. But obviously, if
she really expected to get that much money, which she didn't,
then that would be crazy.
But Destiny consistently says that that's what she wanted, even
though he knows that's not the case. It's just a lie. And that's
like the thing that's upset me the whole time is just the explicit
lies over and over and over again. just explicitly lying again
and again and again and again and again and again and again.
Don't think she even asked for 50 million in her complaint. I
don't think so either. It's pre-trial negotiations which I think
are generally considered to be privileged. You don't leak those.
Um no rule against it but it is a it's a norm to not leak that
you leaked immediately. >> Uh based >> exactly. Are
you able are you able to say how much you've spent so far? Or
is that just not a good >> No, I could. By the end of this,
it wouldn't surprise me, but I probably by the very end of this,
assuming it gets dismissed, an motion for summary judgement.
My guesstimate would be maybe 850k. [sighs] So enough to solo
fund a congressional campaign, which is good stuff. Three times
as much as it would probably cost to a very
somebody asked this
campaign.
Destiny, is your write up going to include all the JTalk and
doxing your friends stuff, too? Uh, it can't, some dude. It literally
can't because then he would have to admit that he just started
doxing people when his friends were already doxed. He would just
have to admit that he was doing this for no reason. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Just good stuff. Three times as much as it would probably
cost to have buried the solo guy. Um, a few sports cars, maybe.
Yeah,
>> probably three times as much as it would have cost to
just settle, you know.
could have just settled. But again, Destiny ran his legal case
like he runs his political opinions. It's entirely spite-based.
Okay. Literally, he will burn his entire bank account to make
sure Pixie doesn't get anything. Very cool. Oh, also, yeah, I
don't know if he's talking about how much it would cost to bury
Solo. Is he talking about who is he paying to Barry Solo? Is
he going to do a civil case against him? Because I would assume
you'd want to go criminal there and get it to the cops as soon
as possible. But >> yeah, that's a lot of money. Oh, >> well
that's, you know, that's good. That [laughter] means you have
to stream for many more years. >> That's actually Hold
on. That's actually good for DG. >> No. Okay. Wait. What
am I looking for?
>> Workshop. Oh, component.
Mechanical component. Now, guess how much Pixie has spent? 30K.
No. Um, they've spent a lot. If I had to guess for all the stuff
that she's done, my guess would be probably a quarter million
so far. That's just a total ballpark because I know how much
like their expert witness cost. It was a good five figure amount.
Um, and like all the weird like they're filing a lot of emotions.
Yeah. I don't know if her family
Destiny is trying to content from this, but he just looks psycho.
Well, he's doing it for his audience, right?
I I want to be like an Well, I do kind of want to be an These
people are like actually a cult and as long as he says it, it's
like true for them. And so he's just like basically doing tone
indicators to show them what's true and what's not true. He develops
and and creates their world, right? So, he needs to keep this
thing. He is running out of money. Like, he is spending a ton
of money on this. So, he needs to keep this thing running. He
can't let this thing fall apart. And I think he didn't expect
to get demonetized in the middle of this. I don't know if he'll
get his channel back or not. It doesn't.
But, like that probably has changed his calculus on a lot of
this stuff and how he feels about it. I'm guessing is paying
for it all or if Joan is doing it pro bono. Maybe it's not Pixie
herself paying because she's worth nothing and has never made
money in her life and is amounts to nothing. His
viewership is very low during the holidays. Less than 2k on YouTube
and kick. Um
maybe
I'm I'm not follow I followed the YouTube stream the other day
when I somebody messaged me and said he was talking to me. I
looked at his YouTube stream. It was like 1.7K.
I was like o
people just don't really like games.
People don't like video games. They'll tell you they like video
games. They just don't love video games. Nothing. But um her
either her parents are paying or Jonah is doing it because she
[__] hates men or something. I don't know. I love
you, John, if you're watching. >> Didn't Candace I don't
know why he's talking about Pixies or whatever. Didn't Candace
get her YouTube remonetized again? I don't know when it was demonetized,
but um like the reason I wouldn't expect it I it could happen.
Like I don't know the reason why I would expect it possibly not
to happen with the monetization stuff. Hold on. I I open the
website that checks. I'll let it load before I say anything because
I want to say why I would expect it not to happen. And then it
loads up and it just says like, "Oh, he got it back."
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. So, one
of his channels, Last Night on Destiny, not remonetized
as of yet. He applied like a week ago or something. I don't know
how long it takes. It might take a while. The reason I wouldn't
suspect it to happen
is almost entirely just that Trump is still in office and I think
the reason they took him down originally was to avoid any scrutiny
from the
and that probably like him going back up while that administration
is still in the throws of fullon like St. Charlie
apologia.
I don't think they're going to unban or remonetize the guy, right?
Because you just think about the campaign that would happen if
um if they remonetized him while
they're still like full-on Charlie Kirk. We have St. Charlie
over here. The guy who was like saying conservatives should be
scared. If they remonetized him right now, I feel like they would
get a lot of Charlie's already forgotten. No, not for the conservatives.
Nope.
Looks like it's not monetized again. Um
I I generally feel like at this point the behavior should get
him deplatformed. So, I have a hard time feeling bad for him
on this front. Yeah. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
we'll see. We'll see what happens.
Think I close this one. Heck this one. Wow. Thank you for the
five tier ones, >> Your honor, look at what he's saying
on my stream. >> I still can't hang over the lies. Do told
Dan can't stream and in her sub tags like she knows she's making
and agreeing to >> lie. Do told Dan can't stream, which
is I've never shot a video with anybody. I've never had sex with
anybody.
Wait, I thought I thought these guys were all like, "You don't
have to reveal those details to people." Is that Is that the
way it is? I can't believe Pixie lied about Destiny and videotaping
it. How could she? How could she? Uh cuz she didn't want it to
go any further than it already had. She was obviously incredibly
humiliated.
I think that's obviously why. To send out tips to any third party
is extremely risky. It's all of it is just dumb.
Like I said, I think that the um the reason why everything is
so is because um she's just really embarrassed to get outed for
streamers. It's like that was like the nightmare scenario for
her is what she was always concerned about. Even in the court
filings, like that's one of the things she fixates on. She's
like, "I told him to make sure nobody knew that we had um relationships
or blah blah blah." But I think it's it's more that because she's
worried it's reputationally damaging or it undermines her credibility.
Chad knows what Chad wants. He's mogging Pixie's legal claims.
I I mostly just sit here and I think like probably
probably Destiny is not the best source of information on something
in his personal life. I don't know about you, I just feel like
there's enough times where Destiny's like, "This is how it is
in my personal life." And then it's the exact opposite, but I'm
like, "Well, I'm already a little suspicious.
Well, I'm already a little h
I will say he is brutally mogging her in the court of public
opinion
and spending all resources to do so. If he doesn't win in the
court of law at this point, he would be totally [__]
I do think he's going to win in the court of law because I think
the claim was really difficult to prosecute to begin with. Fortunately,
he's got like a lot of other claims out there.
Um, we'll see. Um, when you were in DGG, did you ever genuinely
think he was a better person than Hassan? There was probably
some period of time around the time where he was trying to Lauren
Southern, so he's faking being Christian or faking some sort
of a religious awakening possibly that I thought he was a genuinely
like a good person that he was like figuring stuff out and but
obviously when it came out why he was doing that, I'm like, "Oh,
well Jesus." So, probably around that time, at least said it
best, this guy's not a reliable auditor of his own actions. Yeah.
basically, basically, basically, um,
ever watch Hassan to know and now I wonder how much is a straw
man. I think Hassan's political beliefs are fairly shallow. Um,
he does operate on aesthetics a lot. I just don't think he's
like evil. I don't think he's like the evil socialist driving
people towards like a tanky revolution.
I think it probably stops short of that. He's like a fairly shallow
guy who's mostly like could have just played video games and
probably been really popular.
He just happened to do politics and have like an aesthetic, but
that aesthetic is sort of irrelevant to why he became popular
in my opinion. Anyway, >> anyway, I think that's going
to be it. We'll see. >> Uh multiple times in terms of what's
happened and who's lied and what's going on.
I think that um I don't know who believes me because I there
are so many crazy conspirac I would also like to say that my
story has been basically unchanged since the very beginning of
this dude my story has been basically the same since the beginning.
Okay. Uh, by the way, the original story was I had implied consent,
basically relying on us believing that he thought that he had
consent to send a tape of Pixie to an 18-year-old worker he'd
known for seven days that he couldn't verify the identity of.
They couldn't verify the age of, right?
Like he'll say his stories remain consistent.
I maybe he'll lay out what's remained consistent the whole time.
Yeah, the original story was I violated your consent in the worst
way possible twice. He said it, >> but somehow I have no
credibility. Um, but everybody else I mean after after the um
after the whole thing with the Willie Mack DMs, I don't know
how you could think this guy has credibility anymore
where he just like gaslights against like the most obvious,
you're obviously retaining videos of somebody underage. There
is no other way to possibly answer this. You have absolutely
no credibility. story has changed like multiple times in terms
of what's happened and who's lied and what's going on. It's like
okay. But um the Abby uh Abby is not where does Destiny argue
something in Pixie's deposition makes her sound inconsistent
with who had consent. I think he said he didn't have any idea
that she sent the video of them to her boyfriend or something.
But like my understanding of this was
that he very much was aware that like the reason they were taping
it was explicitly to share with that boyfriend
and that like the idea that he was unaware of this is kind of
crazy and that she had already like by the time he started spreading
that narrative that had been in filings that she shared it with
her boyfriend for like weeks.
>> I've never sent anything to Abby so I know she's lying.
I know she's perjuring herself. but also jail time for perjury
or is just all of their testimony not worth anything in the future
like if they actually got it. >> Uh I don't know what the
criminal liability is on a civil case for that. I imagine it
would depend some district >> assume that it should be
criminal but >> I don't know maybe it was really bad. Maybe
a prosecutor would take it up but it'll hurt that court case.
Yeah.
>> Well in this >> well his his argument is like
oh she has implied consent. His argument would be that she can
share it because she has implied consent and that she's a hypocrite.
It's not to be clear like yeah that's not you guys are getting
it a little off here in the chat. Um the argument would be I
think the implied consent is a thing and so I would have by implication
provided consent for her boyfriend but I didn't even know that.
But since I didn't know that obviously you know I could sue her
for the same
>> case it would kill the court case cuz she's the only
evidence. Huh.
[sighs and gasps] Um okay husks. Oh, wait. We're on this. >> Fix
my crosshair after this. This the social terrible >> ch
reminder. Liberal women can see with anyone. It doesn't undermine
their credibility. Women can be horny for men with clout loo
maybe. Well, in the space she was debating at the time, the red
pill space. It would have under she would have felt like it would
have undermined her credibility. But >> would it have totally
undermined Desty's credibility, too, which is why he went nuclear
on Lav for leaking it. He obviously told Lav about it. He obviously
didn't care about what Pixie thought in the first place, which
is why he told people. Um I it used to be that I was always chill
with other streamer YouTuber people that if we hooked up I would
always tell like hey listen like I'll keep this private if you're
cool to keep it or if you want me to keep it private like I won't
say anything obviously because I don't want to
>> shout to the left >> do anything like that but
now I just don't ever >> Oh he Lav came out and said that
like Pixie Destiny and Destiny obviously told Lav a bunch of
like other streamers he'd
something of a pattern of doing this just to be clear. He doesn't
say it in public, but he is perfectly happy to if he's not sharing
videos or whatever the [__] with other people, he's
perfectly happy to tell his current partners who he's [__]
in the past, which is kind of gross when you think about it.
>> Or with or hook up with or interact with streamer YouTuber
people, any of that. Oh, our good friend.
>> The Bastion, the underpass.
>> What' she say? Where is Bastion? Or there's Bastion.
Wait, what was it? >> Nerf Bastion. >> Oh, Nerf Bastion.
>> Okay, I don't know if there's anything else here. Somebody
watch this. Nobody cares. Am I crazy or do I remember some arguments
between you and him about how he can only pick up women because
of his clout and money? Oh, I argued that like his advice was
pretty stupid that like basically he was arguing that like clout
didn't really make that much of a difference because he was so
charismatic and I'm like you're literally just lying. You're
like totally full of like I I do think charisma helps, but he
was basically just arguing that like having clout didn't help
and then you find out who he's and it's literally only people
who know him from stream.
It's It's like obviously not true. Like that that he was just
so charismatic or is so stupid. No, charisma is not an S tier
stat. Charisma is like an A tier stat.
Like literally every element of your looks is an S tier stat.
That's what overcomes. Okay?
There is no five out of 10 on planet Earth who pulls insane by
just being charismatic.
I'm telling you, it doesn't exist.
Now, they can find people who like them, right?
Absolutely. Anybody. You're never going to be forever alone if
you're charismatic. But you're not going to be like swimming
in if you're charismatic. It just depends on what you want.
No, no, no, no. That's not blackpilled. You can absolutely find
somebody if you're charismatic. 100%. I'm just telling you that
like just because you're charismatic doesn't mean you're going
to get laid all the time. You need to be attractive as well.
There's probably some bar where you could Oh, dude, don't make
me do red pills for the love of God. Don't make me do the dating.
But there's probably some bar that's reasonably attainable where
you could be attractive enough with just like the gym and a diet
and all of this where if you're very charismatic, it's not going
to be like a your attractiveness isn't going to be like a thing
for you. Okay. She's I me I don't want to do this. >> Nerf
bastion.
>> I've decided to come back from kick because this place
seems to have been cleaned up in comparison to when it comes
to juiceers guzzlers left after what the [__] was
that sentence?
>> Make sure to go over your fees when you're done. can
always try to get those
>> Okay. Um I was told that >> getting those back
>> by my law firm that in the United States of America,
you're always basically always paying your legal fees. That like
getting legal fees back from the other party is incredibly rare.
They have to up a lot. Um and and I thought these people were
deleting evidence and and like conspiring to not just delete
evidence, but fabricate evidence. Wouldn't that be like up a
lot? Shouldn't you have a ton of evidence of them up a lot? You
made a lot of
>> Well, Joan hased up in my opinion.
>> Mark Courier down there. >> I'm looting that.
Oh, >> now he's going to start managing expectations and
nobody is going to see that this is like the Nobody's going to
see the magic trick, right? About how he totally ramped them
up on how much of a victim he was. How all of the how Jones or
Pixie's team, Joan and and the legal team were totally like breaking
the law. they were totally going to get disbarred,
right? All of this. And now he's slowly walking it back to like,
well, in my opinion, they've done really bad things, but you
know, I don't know. I don't know if we're going to get anything
back, guys. >> Is that another one? >> Down there.
>> What is it? >> Down there. >> All right.
[sighs and gasps] >> Um, Damn it. Careful. >> What
else do we have for today? We got other stuff.
>> Uh, ladder here. So yeah, your law firm basically said,
"Hey, don't count on fees, buck up." >> That's Yeah, basically.
Yeah.
>> Although, who knows? Maybe they were just saying that
because they didn't want me to like take out a loan and not be
able to pay back or something.
>> I will say that like for all the memes about like blood
sucking lawyers and um like I've seen screenshots of people saying
like, "Oh, Brent loves to milk Destiny Drive." Like their advice
to me at the beginning, you know, they said, you know, um, well,
I shouldn't say,
>> but yeah,
>> cover a pisco calling Dan a [__] I >> they
were like very,
their advice has always been, in my opinion, like very like money
maximizing, respectful of client like, yeah,
he doesn't want to say, but we all know it's true.
Rettler definitely told him settle for like 150k or 200k, right?
I guarantee you
I would bet so much money that Bretler was like settle for like
150k. Maybe we get this down to like 100k 75. But like we'll
start at we'll start at 75. I'll push hard and if we get to like
100k, you give me the okay at 100k. If if it keeps going, we'll
do like another two weeks. We'll do 125 and then another like
month and then we'll do 150. Okay. But we need to get this settled.
That's the best way you could do this.
>> I'm talking about from your law firm. Ha. They got to
justify their billing. >> Well, I mean, when they send
me their invoices, they give me the breakdown and
Sentinel firing, please.
I got it. Okay, I'm done playing this game forever. Just
hold on. Why is Darius just lying? Why Why is Darius just lying
here? Hold on. Apparently, there's some food shops clip that
got posted by Substance. Maybe we'll check it out in a little
bit. >> No, actually, >> I don't know what this is.
Wait, why is food shops on here? Am I watching food shops? I
don't EVEN KNOW WHAT I'M WATCHING. WHAT am I looking at? It's
reaction.
Okay. Talk wants to know where the Oh, no. It's me watching food
shops. Watch Pisco. Watch something. Um, by the way, I didn't
go to this guy's house. This is me talking about Riyle in the
whole thing. He says, "I pulled up at my house 5 seconds later."
Uh, I believe, hold on. I believe that the addresses were very,
very close if I'm not mistaken. He's I I feel like he is doing
something here to go and say he's trying to make it seem like,
well, I pulled up really quick back at home. And it's like, "Yeah,
isn't that why you went there in the first place? Wasn't it because
you he was like really close to you or something?" He claims
he was pretending. He says he was pretending, guys. I was just
pretending. Great joke, though. Great joke. Great great joke.
But I'm I'm pretty sure that's what it is. I Maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe I'm wrong. The people being Indian makes too much sense.
I actually stopped at my parents house.
Well, okay. Um
don't post the Destiny messages.
Dude, Discord, you suck. Discord, stop. Discord, stop.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I don't know how much further
we have to go on this. God, get me out. Get me out. [laughter]
>> It's so funny to me. You're going through the billing.
Uh, uh, Annie B, what the hell is this? >> Yeah, except
to ask them about the billing. They probably invoice me. >> Now
that I think about it, I think I photoshopped those cyber emails.
They weren't ever real either >> for those hours, too.
So, was your lawyer? Is he even aware he was added on >> Um,
yeah, he's definitely aware. Yeah.
>> Oh my god, dude. That depo was so funny.
>> Oh, yeah. Right. >> I don't think so. Lauren asked
her to be out. One of my favorite things that this is the thing
that I was legitimately worried about is like Lauren is definitely
the type of girl. There are some women, Lab does this too, where
you can tell they're used to getting away with um because they're
like hot women. Oh my god, it was so funny. I think after the
first hour or two, Lauren was like very bubbly and excited and
happy and like yapping way too much or whatever. And I think
um at some point I think Andy's like um if you just answer the
questions in a straightforward manner, like we can get through
this a lot quicker. Like it doesn't have to take so long. And
then she was like I think Loner's like um oh are you asking me
to come back for a second deposition? Kind of like another date.
And I'm like oh god. I'm like I hope Andy doesn't like you know
blow this girl's ego up or whatever. And um
Andrew was like, "Did you just ask me out on a date? Can you
let the record reflect that I think that's incredibly inappropriate?"
I was like, "Oh my god, it was so funny." For the next 6 hours,
she was so deflated. It was so hilarious.
Holy sh. She got so mad. Let the record. Okay. Wow. That's super
cool.
And he's super cool. I do wonder why he would be hostile to the
person
who you hate. Person who's paying him a whole bunch of money.
Why you'd be hostile to someone you hate? That's so confusing.
I've never seen that play out ever before.
Very shocking. Very
Uh, okay.
Where are we going? Where are we going? What are we doing? I
think that's basically it. Okay. I think that's like God, that's
got to be it. That's got to be it. That's got to be it. I This
is my fault. I normally put this stuff off and like leave it
for later by actually preparing content for a stream and I just
didn't do that today. So, I ended up just covering this [__]
cuz I was lazy.